do we do it there yes we do
so so what I'm wanting to do is today
for you to go home and not just forget
it on your Tuesday class or whatever
night you have your class I want you to
I want you to have it so that you're
never going to let the tiger back in the
cage you know it's out there yeah
it's not being a bully it's expelling a
coat and you'll then go
well it feels really powerful looking at
him role but I don't actually feel it so
you won't feel Coke you won't feel your
own power
it's difficult
you will feel your strength because when
you go like that and you have to push a
bit extra
you'll feel your strength
but if you keep doing it long enough
your Coke you this monster
comes out
and then you see you go on we'll say to
what me and Ronnie were talking about
you go on to this
oh
key power force
power that you can't see
and that's what you saw in the ocean oh
Scentsy when he was very old they used
to he used to sort of like call him up
and and they'd be falling back down
before they could get on their feet and
they and people go why is they why are
they rolling about and it's because
obviously
and I hopefully don't want to get nearer
to death just yet but uh but I think the
near closer we get to death I think
martial artists especially they're all
builds naturally if they've been on the
right path
so then
that's what I believe I've since had